les spectacles maintenant bon sang ne
saurait mentir quand on a un père
excellent comédien
que faire d'autre sinon devenir soi-même
une bonne comédienne chez les
trintignant qui sont nos invités
on pratique l'art de la comédie de père
en fille était vraie france roche en ce
moment les trintignant sont à la fiche
sur plusieurs foot
amélie la bande trintignant frappe trois
fois pendant que nadine trintignant la
mer termine le montage d'une série
télévisée avec michel bourgois jeanne
moreau jean louis qui tourne un film en
présente un autre qui s'appelle l'homme
aux yeux d'argent de pierre
granier-deferre et marie-jo théâtre au
café de la gare
alors on va commencer par le papa qui
est dans le film de granier-deferre donc
le monde y est d'argent un très méchant
policiers et de surcroît homosexuels qui
entretient avec son adjoint des rapports
très douteux alors vous allez voir qu'il
est très méchant contre le pauvre à
ladesou souchon ici qui est une
véritable publicité pour le crime
devraient savoir à quoi vous jouez
vous est reconnue vous êtes un des flics
un de ceux qui vont interroger
qu'est ce que vous voulez j'ai fait mon
temps ne doit plus rien à personne et
l'argent c'est très bien que c'est pour
moi qu'il est alors foutez moi la paix
je suis chez moi ici chez toi
mais la personne ici des parents sont
morts l'affirmait dès rasé on est plus
personne personne ne te connais bien
plus rien ici sauf l'argent l'argent et
moi coûts de l'énergie
je sais que tu reviennes bush a reçu
l'argent mais il est sale cet argent il
est plein de sang au jeu suit une cure à
le sens d'un flic tu t'en fous toi hein
je suis venu parce que c'est ici que
j'habite d'accord moi aussi mais je vais
te dire une chose quand tu leur as
retrouvé l'argent je serai là c'est pas
un tribunal qui te jugera si moi tout
seul à lévis voilà un extrait de l'homme
aux yeux d'argent donc avec jean louis
trintignant qui est notre invité nous
allons parler tout de suite mais france
il faut parler de ce que fait la fille
marie trintignant cette fois c'est du
théâtre du café thé et du café théâtre
mais c'est toujours de la police
seulement alors que le père est très
méchant avec son partenaire alain
souchon et bien marie trintignant elle
est très méchante avec le policier
policiers qui est joué par philippe
manesse dans les méthodes de camille
bourreau une comédie policière un peu
farfelue vous allez voir comme elle
aussi elle tape au café de la gare
qu'est ce qui vous prend vector me
cogner pas je suis à booty les fesses
balande où ils écoutent et moi vous êtes
en danger écoutez moi mais c'est quoi je
sais que j'ai fait ici
à valence je ne supporte pas qu'on
voudrait d'un v6 solution mais c'est un
domaine bulletin de sacy connard oui là
ça va ça va pour faire attention à bout
au monde ils appellent maintenant mais
dans cette mer si j'aurais dû partir du
bois je suis sauvé parole est mort
merde écrabouillé sous sa douche et
panade aussi on a appris des tas leurs
pendants quel foutoir de tellement de
fourrer mais votre petit pois vont
porter le pasteur vous élisez marie
trintignant en colère au café de la gare
jean louis trintignant comment voulez
vous trouvez votre fille sublime non je
sais pas c'est vous dites agiles monde
professionnel aller vite mais elle est
magnifique mais je l'avais vit déjà au
théâtre parce qu'elle a déjà joué au
théâtre une pièce très dramatique de
dostoïevski et là j'ai vu dans une pièce
comique et elle est formidable elle m'a
vraiment étonné voulu donner des
conseils parfois oh non il ya rien à
dire non mais quand même solide et
parfois non nous quand elle a voulu
commencer à être comme etienne l'a fait
encouragé ou vous lui avez dit tout ce
qu'on dit aux enfants quand on est
comédien c'est difficile tu verras passe
d'abord tombak non je n'ai pas encore
âgé du tour je crois qu'il faut
décourager tous les gens qui veulent
être comédien mais ceux qui veulent
vraiment l'être le seront de toute façon
le départ il faut décourager les gens
c'est vrai vous allez courage et marie
oui mais bon pas vraiment pas vraiment
donc en fait vous avez toujours voulu
tendre âge est vétérinaire puis après
j'ai vu être courtisane
mélange des deux c'était quand est ce
que ça vous à privas non vers 16 ans 16
16 17
alors votre père a donné son avis tout à
l'heure sur votre prestation vous avez
vu son film j'imagine le monsieur d'art
jean alesi maintenant dit tout ce que
vous pensez via vient en effet j'aime
bien aller re de méchant dans les rôles
de méchants oui vous préférez mais quand
vous étiez petit
est-ce que vous aimiez le voir jouer des
scènes d'amour avec une autre personne
par exemple ou se faire taper dessus à
vous n'alliez pas renom wigg à mesure
qu'on vieillit on est beaucoup plus
d'argent pour ses parents puis c'est
plus intéressant mon petit franchement
c'était pas des chiens qui s'est
beaucoup
alors revenons au film que vous jouez
jean louis trintignant l'homme aux yeux
d'argent france le 18 août à l'heure
vous jouez un rôle ambigu un rôle de
policier homosexuels c'est un rôle assez
difficile j'imagine oui oui c'est très
amusant je me suis beaucoup amusé c'est
vrai que je me sens souvent plus à
l'aise dans des personnages qui me sont
un petit peu étranger parce que je suis
très pudique alors quand je joue très
près de moi de ce que je suis je suis
toujours un petit peu coincé en éclats
je me défoule de tout ce qu'il ya de mal
en moins même pour taper sur sochaux là
ça pose pas problème ce trou et il est
délicieux
vous venez de commencer
un homme une femme vingt ans après ça
doit être drôle quand même de se
remettre dans le costume du personnage
qu'on était il ya vingt ans non parce
que l'aja fait son travail et et ses 20
ans le film s'appelle vingt ans déjà
c'est joli je trouve pas ce que c'est
pour tout le monde de gygrid 20 ans mais
logique
les spectateurs qui ont aimé ce simon
11e 20 ans il faut dire vous recommencez
donc avec anouk aimée oui sous la
direction pour le loge de logis pour ça
que jean bart c'est pas du tout parce
que je suis négliger j'ai un début de
marne marie trintignant alors revenons
en vous à votre pièce au café-théâtre
ainsi une caisse de sotta faut quand
même le dire parce que c'est elle est la
base du café théâtre elle a créé
beaucoup de pièces est les bouteilles et
c'est une pièce très drôle
c'est une comédie policière formidable
moi je m'entraîne mène la soupe mais je
trouve ça très grave ou entrer dans la
bande donc du café théâtre c'est une
bonne école du café de la gare oui oui
c'est une bonne école parce que c'est il
ya il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
permis c'est que c'est très ouvert
beaucoup plus qu'une pièce classique
france est ce que vous avez trouvé le
moyen de jouer ensemble ou est ce que
vous voulez éviter ce genre de choses
vous avez d'ailleurs joué avec
jean-louis quand vous étiez toute petite
année les mâles l'internet une d'armes
moi je j'ai écrit un sujet que je ferai
peut-être dans
trois ans qui est une histoire d'amour
entre un homme
muret une jeune femme et je voudrais le
faire avec marie parce que c'est une
histoire d'amour qui n'aboutit pas si
sûr d'amour qui pourrait aboutir et qui
n'aboutit pas et qu'est ce qu'elle en
dit elle ça n'a pas fait rire non pas
des stickers
merci jean louis trintignant merci marie
trintignant donc l'homme au lieu
d'argent jean louis trintignant au
cinéma et france on rappelle le titre la
pièce de marie trintignant
les méthodes de camille bon road sauta
au café de la gare merci beaucoup
il est l'heure de